mom looks pretty good right now he looks
hot
i'm surprised i've never seen her look
like this before my entire life she's a
mouth she's a very handsome woman
huh
very handsome milf
she looks darling
so what time is your date
it should be any time now
i'm really nervous are you yeah why
we're going on a second date and you
know hoping it'll you know it
kind of exciting looking forward to it i
really haven't talked to him very much
since then i'm texting back and forth
there hasn't been a lot of communication
have you talked to them today
today no yesterday but i really haven't
heard anything bad
[Music]
maybe something happened
maybe he has a flat tire
i'd give him a call
yeah let's call him i think so
okay let's do this
hi
jay is currently unavailable please
speak clearly your voicemail is being
transcribed by email message
where are you
wherever the date
thank you very much
okay then he forwarded that
did he yeah he sent it to voicemail you
can do that i mean you can tell the
difference yeah it rang once and then it
went to voicemail that usually means you
were ignored
why
he's avoiding the call
what a piece
[Music]
i never realized what the expression
ghosting was until now and i don't know
this is how people
treat each other now dating in today's
life
but not to call or text
i don't deserve it it's not right
it makes me feel like uh i'm not worth
the effort to type
five seconds typing something like
something you know you know something
else bitter came up but i'm not gonna
have the courtesy to tell you like it's
doesn't matter you know no
i'm not gonna bother with you
[Music]
you